savez vous vous êtes en ce moment je
fais des essais cliniques
qu'est-ce qui tourne pas rond chez oh je
suis malade
et je m'en moque selon vous qu'est ce
que ces essais cliniques pourraient
révéler sur vos même envie de l'abc
maintenant on ne se met pas de l'abc
c'est de la science dès que vous
commencez à percevoir la structure de
l'esprit vous réalisez que tout ce qui
fait ce que nous sommes peut-être changé
la douleur peut être détruite
l'esprit
n'est pas insoluble parmi les sujets
combien ont fini catatonique 0 pour
l'instant
ma tête on fonctionne pas bien tu ne
figure que ces gens vont soigner c'est
stupide
moi je ne trouve pas ça stupide du tout
ok parfait on y va
depuis
mon cerveau me joue des tours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette histoire de multi réalité c'est
des conneries
c'est pas ce qui est réel ce qui ne
l'est pas
[Musique]
il ya un problème qu'est ce que vous
avez fait
à chaque fois que je laissais part il
trouve le moyen de se rejoindre
tu es loin de protéger ces gens enfermés
là dedans
[Musique]